Natoo : En direct des Bahamas !
Squeezie : Excellent ! Bonjour, nous sommes aux Bahamas avec Cyprien, avec un homme qui revient du Hellfest, c'était bien ?
Julfou : Oui, c'était très bien regarde, nouvelle coupe.
Squeezie : Très très belle coupe ! Et avec... excuse moi, tu es la comédienne du "Manoir" au cinéma depuis la semaine dernière?
Natoo : Tout à fait !
Squeezie : D'ailleurs, "Le Manoir" sort aujourd'hui au moment où on fait cette vidéo, bravo *applaudissements* Un très gros projet qui sort, bravo Natoo !
Cyprien : Aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu de société.
Squeezie : Ouais ! Déjà, ça s'appelle "Ta mère en slip ! C'est bien de le préciser !
Cyprien : Donc, choisissez une paire de lunettes.
Squeezie : Eeeet hop là ! Eh, il y a du budget sur les lunettes quand même ! Il y a vraiment du budget !
Cyprien : Il y a le personnage et le détail qu'on a sur les lunettes !
Squeezie : Et voilà !
*Musique*
Julfou : Ok, très bien !
*Rires*
Squeezie : Alors regarde pas à ta droite parce que il y a un...
Cyprien : Moi je sais pas ce qu'il y a écrit sur ma tête ! Mais celui-là, de Lucas, j'aime beaucoup déjà !
Squeezie : Alors maintenant, comment on procède Cyprien ?
Cyprien : Bah t'as... on a 30 secondes chacun pour poser le plus de questions, de qui on est, et faut répondre, et vous devez répondre par oui ou par non.
Squeezie : Natoo, tu veux commencer ?
Cyprien : Nat, commence !
Natoo : Ok, est-ce que je suis un homme ou une femme ?
Squeezie : Femme !
Natoo : Chanteuse ?
Cyprien : Oui !
Squeezie & Julfou : Oui !
Natoo : Je suis réelle ? J'existe ?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Oui !
Natoo : Euuuh, française ?
Julfou : Non !
Natoo : Américaine ?
Cyprien & Julfou : Non !
Natoo : Oh !
Squeezie : Me regarde pas, j'ai... j'ai pas...
Natoo : Céline Dion ! Céline Dion !
Cyprien : OUI !
Squeezie : Oh !
Cyprien : Putain !
Natoo : J'suis bien ou j'suis pas bien ?
Squeezie : T'es pas très bien ! T'es pas très bien
Julfou : T'es bof !
Cyprien : T'es bof !
*Rires*
Squeezie : La vie...
Natoo : Je suis bourrée !? Je suis bourrée !?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Natoo : J'suis bourrée...
Natoo : J'suis en train de vomir ?
Squeezie : Nan !
Natoo : J'ai de la gastro ?
Cyprien : Hop !
Squeezie : Oh ! C'est fini ! Oh putain t'as trouvé déjà ton perso !
Natoo : La moitié, j'ai la moitié ! J'ai un œil, un œil, qui est validé !
Squeezie : 'Tain, bien joué !
Cyprien : Julfou22
Squeezie : Julien, t'es prêt ?
Julfou : Allez-y !
Squeezie : Attention ! C'est parti !
Julfou : Je suis un homme ?
Squeezie : Oui !
Julfou : Euuuh j'suis... est-ce que j'suis un artiste ?
Cyprien & Squeezie : Nan !
Julfou : Est-ce que je suis un politicien ?
Cyprien & Squeezie : Oui !
Julfou : Ah euh, est-ce que j'suis un politicien sympa ?
Cyprien : Je pense
Squeezie : Euh tranquille !
*Explosion de rire*
Squeezie : On sait pas, mais c'est pas notre poto, je sais pas !
Julfou : Est-ce que je suis de droite ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Julfou : Est-ce que j'exerce encore ?
Cyprien : Terminé !
Squeezie: C'est fini ! C'est fini !
Julfou : Olala !
Cyprien : C'est dur hein !
Natoo : Et bah moi j'ai trouvé !
Cyprien : A toi, vas-y !
Squeezie : Euuh j... un homme ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Natoo : Nan !
Squeezie : Une femme !?
Cyprien : Oui !
Natoo : Argh oui !
Squeezie : Un animal !
Cyprien : Non ! (rit)
Squeezie : Excellent !
Natoo : Nan !
Squeezie : Je suis... euh chanteuse ?
Cyprien & Natoo & Julfou : OUI !
Squeezie : OH !
*Rire de Julfou*
Squeezie : J'ai les cheveux bruns ?
Cyprien : Je sais pas !
Natoo : Ouuuuuu... on sait p..
Julfou : Oui euh si !
Squeezie : Ouais euh ça dépend, un clip sur 2 ?
Squeezie : Je suis blanche !?
Natoo : Oui !
Cyprien : Il y a un truc avec les cheveux !
Squeezie : JE... JE SUIS... MAIS RÉPONDEZ !!! Je suis blanche ?
Natoo : Oui ! Blanche ! Blanche ! Blanche !
Squeezie : Blanche !
Squeezie : Huuum
Cyprien : Il y a un problème de cheveux en tout cas ! *Rires*
Squeezie : C'est fini ! C'est fini ! Bah merci à tous pour votre soutien !
Squeezie : C'est parti !
Julfou : Ah on repart, d'accord !
Cyprien : Je suis un homme ?
Squeezie & Natoo : Nan !
Cyprien : Je suis une femme !?
Squeezie & Natoo : Oui !
Squeezie : Nan !
Cyprien : Je suis américaine ?
Squeezie : Oui !
Cyprien : Je suis jolie ?
Squeezie & Natoo : Oui !!
Cyprien : Je chante, je suis une chanteuse ?
Squeezie & Natoo : Oui !
Cyprien : Américaine... Je suis Katy Perry ?
Squeezie & Natoo & Julfou : Nan !
Cyprien : Je suis...
Squeezie : C'est fini !
Cyprien : Olalaaa !
Squeezie : Ok !
Cyprien : Eh mais vous savez quoi ? Je suis le seul à y avoir déjà joué, je suis le plus nul !
Squeezie : C'est parti !
Natoo : Est-ce que je suis en garde à vue ?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Natoo : Je suis man... menotée ?
Natoo : En jetlag ?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Natoo : C'est compliqué ! Je... je... je suis tombée ? Je me suis blessée ?
Cyprien & Squeezie : Nan !
Natoo : Euh c'est dans un... dans un espace fermé ?
Cyprien & Squeezie : Oui, c'est dans un espace fermé !
Natoo : Ok, j'ai perdu mes clés !?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Ah !
Squeezie : Dommage !
Cyprien : Ça c'est les bonnes questions ! Ça c'est les bonnes questions !
Julfou : Et oui c'est Céline Dion a perdu ses clés *Rires*
Squeezie : Ouais ! 'Tain eh Natoo elle est SU-PER FORTE  !
Squeezie : T'es prêt ? C'est parti !
Julfou : Ok ! Politicien, de gauche euuh...
Cyprien & Squeezie & Natoo : Ouais !
Julfou : On sait pas vraiment si il est sympa...
Squeezie : Ouais !
*Rires*
Squeezie : Connu, très connu !
Natoo : Très très très connu !
Cyprien & Squeezie : Très connu !
Julfou : Vivant encore de justesse !? Chirac, Jacques Chirac !?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Natoo : Nan !
*Rires*
Natoo : Allez, enchaîne ! Enchaîne !
Cyprien : Il exerce plus depuis peu !
Julfou : Euh ah ! Hollande ! François Hollande !?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Natoo : OUIII !
Julfou : Ok, facile !
*Rire de Cyprien*
Squeezie : Ok, situation ?
Julfou : Ok, situation !
Julfou : C'est une situation agréable ou pas agréable ?
Squeezie : Nan, c'est chiant !
Natoo : Pas agréable ! Pas agréable !
Julfou : C'est très chiant !
Julfou : C'est euh... c'est dangereux ?
Natoo : Si tu le fais pas oui !
Squeezie : C'est fini ! C'est fini.
Cyprien : Hop là c'est parti !
Squeezie : Je connais la chanteuse ou pas ?
Cyprien : Oui !
Squeezie : Euh... elle a vendu beaucoup d'albums ?
Squeezie : C'est euh euh... Katy Perry ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Squeezie : Rihanna ?
Cyprien : Française, elle est française !
Natoo : Elle est française !
Squeezie : Ah elle est FRANÇAISE !?
Squeezie : TAL ?
Cyprien : Nan. Ah ! En nombre de lettres et en lettres il est pas loin !
Squeezie : Yannick Noah !?
Cyprien : MAIS C'EST UNE FEMME !
Squeezie : Mais je sais putain !
Cyprien : Il régresse !
Squeezie : Mais je sais pas, mais je vais jamais trouver !!!
Cyprien : Donc je suis une chanteuse !?
Squeezie & Natoo : Ouais !
Cyprien : Je suis très jolie...
Squeezie : Ouais ! Américaine !
Cyprien : Euh... je suis Beyoncé !? Je suis de couleur blanche ?
Squeezie : Ouais !
Cyprien : Je suis pas Katy Perry, je suis américaine, je suis... TAYLOR SWIFT !
Squeezie & Natoo : OUI !
Cyprien : Oh YES !
Cyprien : Je... je... je vais pas bien !?
Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Cyprien : Pas bien... je suis bourré !?
Squeezie & Julfou : OUIII !
Cyprien : Je suis euh... Taylor Swift bourrée !
Squeezie (applaudissant) : Ouais !
Cyprien : OUIII !
Cyprien : Je suis très satisfait d'avoir gagné puisque les parties que j'ai faites avant, je... je perdais tout le temps !
Natoo : Oooooooohhhhhhhh !
Squeezie : Alors, Natoo t'es prête ?
Cyprien : Tu es dans un endroit, c'est parti !
Natoo : Je suis enfermée aux toilettes ?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Natoo : Dans une... boîte de nuit ?
Natoo : Je suis dans des... *Rire*
Julfou : Moins agréable, moins agréable !
Natoo : ... WC publics ?
Natoo : Les... le... les... pour aller faire tes papiers dans une préfecture !
Squeezie : Aah, on est pas loin, on est pas loin !
Natoo : Pas le commissariat... Euh...
Squeezie : C'est fini ! C'est fini...
Natoo : Ah putain...
Cyprien : T'es pas loin, elle est pas loin du tout !
Julfou : Moi j'ai oublié les indices déjà !
*Rires*
Julfou : Enfin, je sais que c'est François Hollande mais...
Squeezie : Ok, top !
Cyprien : Qui fait quelque chose !
Julfou : Euh c'est François Hollande... Ah, qui fait quelque chose !
Julfou : Ah, François Hollande qui... qui est dans un film porno !?
Squeezie & Natoo : Nan !
Julfou : Euh est-ce que c'est un endroit qui... où on a pas le droit d'aller ?
*Gros blanc*
Natoo : Bah si, faut y aller !
Julfou : Haha, je pose des questions de merde !
*Rire de Squeezie*
Julfou : Tout le monde fait genre... t'sais
Cyprien : Chanteuse, 3 lettres, c'est parti !
Natoo : Franchement...
Cyprien : Fais l'alphabet sinon !
Squeezie : A, alors est-ce que ça commence par A ?
Cyprien : Non.
Squeezie : Par B ?
Natoo : Ah bah si il fait l'alphabet c'est... *Rire*
Squeezie : Par C ?
Squeezie : D ? E F G H I J K L M N O P Q R S T
*Rires*
Squeezie : U V W X Y Z ? *Rire*
Cyprien : OUI ! OUI !
Squeezie (tape dans ses mains) : Zoé !
Cyprien : Nan !
Natoo : Mais enfiiiin !!!
Squeezie : Zoé...
Cyprien : Fais la 2ème lettre !
Squeezie : 2ème lettre, 2ème lettre !
Natoo : Enfiiinnn...
Squeezie : Est-ce qu'elle commence par A B C...
Cyprien : Oui !
Squeezie : A !
*Natoo fredonne un aire de ZAZ*
Squeezie : ZA... ZA...
Julfou : Il la connaît pas, il la connaît tellement pas ! *Rire*
Natoo : Mais en...
Squeezie : ZAZ !!!
Cyprien & Natoo & Julfou : OUI !
*Rire*
Natoo : Putaiin !
Squeezie : Eh mais ZAZ, j'pensais qu'il y avait un E
*Rires*
Natoo : Oooooh noooooon !
Squeezie : Voilà, anecdote ! Tout Paris sait maintenant !
Cyprien : ZAZE !
Squeezie : ZAZE
Squeezie : Nat !?
Natoo : Ouais !
Squeezie : Top !
Natoo : J'suis à la Poste ?
Cyprien & Squeezie : Nan !
Squeezie & Julfou : Oooh !
Cyprien : Un endroit ! Administratif !
Squeezie : Administratif...
Natoo : Euuuuuuh...
Squeezie : Ouais, ouais, là tu tiens un truc là !
Natoo : Voilà, je vais attendre comme ça (*Rire de Squeezie*) que le sablier... passe !
Cyprien : Terminé !
Julfou : Euh... la garde à vue ? En garde à vue !?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Natoo : Nan !
Julfou : Euh... j'suis en...
Cyprien : Il y a un indice sur ma carte !
Julfou : Euh... d'accord, je suis en cure de désintox !?
Natoo : OUIIIIII !
Squeezie : Ooooh !
Squeezie : Alors, faut dire, vite, vite ! Dis tout !
Julfou : Ah euh, aaaarrrrgggh
Squeezie : Ah, c'est trop tard ! *Rire*
Cyprien : ZAZE, allez !
Squeezie : Ok, c'est un état ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Squeezie : C'est une action ?
Squeezie : Je suis dans un endroit ?
Cyprien : Oui !
Squeezie : C'est pas très cool !? Euh...
Julfou : Ah non, c'est pas très cool du tout ! *Rire*
Squeezie : C'est pas très cool du tout !?
Squeezie : C'est à Paris ?
Cyprien & Julfou : Nan !
Squeezie : C'est en France ?
Cyprien & Natoo & Julfou : Nan !
Squeezie : C'est aux US ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Squeezie : C'est sur la planète ?
Cyprien & Natoo : Oui !
Squeezie : C'est... c'est réel ?
Cyprien & Natoo & Julfou : Oui !
Squeezie : Ok, suivant.
Natoo : Je suis perdue ! Je sais PAAS !
Squeezie : Mais bien sûr que si, réfléchis ! Allez, c'est parti !
Natoo : Je sais pas !
Cyprien : Fais les lettres ! Fais les lettres, fais les lettres !
Natoo : A B C D E F G H I J K L M N O... M ?
Cyprien : Nan après !
Natoo : N ?
Squeezie : Après !
Natoo : OOOOO
Cyprien & Squeezie : Après !
Natoo : P ?
Squeezie : OUI !
Natoo : Poliice, c'est la poliice !
Cyprien : Allez, 2ème lettre, c'est parti, c'est parti, 2ème lettre !
Natoo : A B C D E F G H I J K L M N O...
Squeezie : Oui !
Cyprien : L M N...
Natoo : O !
Cyprien : Oui !
Cyprien & Squeezie : Au Pô...
Natoo : Pô... Poste !
*Explosion de rires*
Natoo : Mais on y revient toujours ! La préfecture et la poste, C'EST NUL !
Natoo : Laissez-moiiiii !
Julfou : Ola, j'ai encore oublié ! Euh...
Natoo : J'vais faire une sieste !
Julfou, Ah oui si oui, maintenant c'est facile, je suis euh... François Hollande en cure de désintoxication !
Cyprien & Squeezie : OUIIIIIIII !
Natoo : ÇA Y EST JE L'AIIII !!!!
*Rires*
Natoo : JE L'AI ! Ça y est !
Cyprien : Allez, c'est parti !
Squeezie : Ok, donc c'est un lieu réel !?
Cyprien : Oui !
Squeezie : C'est grand ?
Cyprien : C'est grand !
Squeezie : C'est un pays ?
Cyprien : Aaah ! Il est fort !
Squeezie : C'est un pays !
Squeezie : Euuuuuuh, c'est un pays euh b... touristique ?
Julfou : Ooooh, bof !
Cyprien (en riant) : Pas du tout !
Squeezie : Putain mais c'est quoi ?
Squeezie : C'est où, c'est vers les US ?
Cyprien & Julfou : Nan !
Natoo : Afff...
Squeezie : C'est vers l'Europe ?
Cyprien : Nan
Natoo : Offf...
Squeezie : C'est vers l'Australie ?
Julfou : Bah euh...
Squeezie : MAIS PUTAIN MAIS C'EST PAS POSSIBLE !!!
Cyprien : Fais les continents merde !
Squeezie : C'est en Afrique ?
Natoo : OH ! C'EST TERMINÉ !
Squeezie : En France ?
Natoo : C'EST TERMINÉ !
Squeezie : ESPÈCE DE MENTEUSE IL EN RESTAIT !
Natoo : Je suis Céline Dion au Pôle emploi !
*Rires*
Natoo : OUAAIIIS !!
Cyprien : Alors maintenant t'es online sur toi !
Squeezie : Mais je suis une merde !
Natoo : Ah non !
Julfou : Pose des questions sur le pays !
Squeezie : Vous y êtes déjà allés ?
Cyprien & Julfou : Nan !
Squeezie : Est-ce qu'un ami à vous y est déjà allé ?
Cyprien & Julfou : Un seul !
Squeezie : États-Unis, Afrique du Sud, euuuh... A... Amérique du Sud, Amérique du Nord, Antarctique...
Julfou : T'oublies vraiment un continent énorme !
Cyprien : Il est comme aç !
Squeezie : Australie, Europe...
Squeezie : Asie !
Cyprien & Julfou : Oui !
Squeezie : Aaaah !
Squeezie : Corée du Nord !
Cyprien & Julfou : Oui !
Cyprien : Attends, attends, t'es... tu es...
Squeezie : Je suis ZAZ en Corée du Nord
Cyprien : Nan, ZAZ...
Squeezie : Z-E en Corée du Nord !
Cyprien : Voilà !
Squeezie : C'est stressant ce jeu, j'arrête ! J'arrête, je vous laisse faire la 2ème game sans moi, je suis stressé !
Cyprien : On fait... on fait une 2ème game !?
Squeezie : Allez, on fait une 2ème game !
Cyprien : Vu que j'ai déjà joué plusieurs fois, j'ai un niveau un peu élevé, du coup ils me trouvent des cartes custom, qu'ils inventent !
Cyprien : Et ça c'est... voici les lunettes de Lucas !
Julfou (avec une voix de débile) : C'est bon !
Cyprien : C'est bon !?
*Musique*
Cyprien : Je vais le mettre !?
Squeezie : Ouais !
Cyprien : Est-ce que j'vais galérer de ouf à trouver ?
Squeezie : Oh, non, non, non non c'est jouable !
Squeezie : Ok, on est ti-par !
Natoo : Homme ?
Squeezie : Oui !
Natoo : Youtubeur ?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Natoo : Chanteur ?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Oui !
Natoo : Français ?
Natoo : Booba !?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Natoo : Euh... La Fouine !?
Natoo : C'est un groupe ? Nan ? Tout seul ?
Squeezie : Tout seul !
Natoo : Tout seul...
Squeezie : Mais il a été dans un groupe !
Natoo : Nekfeu !?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Squeezie : Et c'est fini !
Squeezie : Julfou ?
Julfou : Oui ?
Squeezie : On y va !
Julfou : Euh ok euh chanteur ?
Cyprien & Natoo : Nan !
Julfou : Euh... musicien ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Julfou : Euh... politicien ?
Cyprien & Natoo : Nan !
Julfou : Euuh... animateur ?
Julfou : Euuuuuh... Sportif !?
Cyprien & Squeezie & Natoo : Nan !
Squeezie : Pas du tout, pas du tout !
Natoo : Naaan ! Pas du tout ! Là...
Squeezie : Vraiment pas !
Cyprien : L'opposé du sportif !
Julfou : Youtubeur !?
*Rires*
Squeezie : Et c'est fini !
Squeezie : Je suis un homme ?
Cyprien : Ouais !
Squeezie : Je suis un acteur ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Squeezie : Je suis un chanteur ?
Cyprien & Natoo : Nan !
Squeezie : Je suis un politicien ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Squeezie : Je suis Youtubeur ?
Squeezie : Je suis réel ?
Cyprien & Natoo & Julfou : Euh... nan !
Squeezie : Je suis issu d'un animé !?
Cyprien & Natoo & Julfou : Ouaaiis !
Cyprien : 'Fin nan, d'un de...
Squeezie : D'un dessin animé !?
Cyprien : Ouais
Squeezie : D'un dessin animé... japonais ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Squeezie : D'un dessin animé... belge ?
Squeezie : D'un dessin animé africain ?
Cyprien (en riant) & Natoo : Nan !
Julfou : Olala mais... fioouu
Squeezie : Créé par ZAZ ?
*Rires*
Cyprien : Je suis un homme ?
Squeezie & Natoo & Julfou : Oui !
Cyprien : J'passe à la télé ?
Squeezie : Oui !
Cyprien : Euuh... les gens l'aiment bien ?
Squeezie : Ça dépend !
Natoo : Moi j'l'aime bien !
Julfou : Moi ça va !
Cyprien : J'suis dans la musique ?
Squeezie & Julfou : Oui !
Cyprien : Je suis chanteur ?
Cyprien : Français ?
Squeezie & Natoo & Julfou : Oui !
Squeezie : Et c'est trop tard !
Cyprien : Olala !
Squeezie : Putain, cette partie elle est incroyable ! Cette partie elle est incroyable, c'est le suspens !
Julfou : Réalisateur ?
Cyprien & Squeezie : Nan !
Julfou : Acteur ?
Cyprien & squeezie & Natoo : Oui !
Julfou : Acteur... Ah, j'ai pas dit acteur !?
Squeezie : Non
Julfou : Richard Bohringer ?
Cyprien : Non !
*Rires*
Squeezie : Arrêtez de donner des noms comme ça !
Squeezie : Et donc je viens d'un dessin animé !?
Natoo : Oui !
Squeezie : Alors d'où vient le dessin animé ? Il est français ?
Cyprien & Natoo & Julfou : Mais nan !
Squeezie : Il est américain ?
Natoo : OUIIIIII !
Squeezie : Un dessin animé américain !?
*Rires*
Cyprien : Il arrive... sur la planète Terre... UN DESSIN ANIMÉ AMÉRICAIN !
Squeezie : Futurama ?
Cyprien & Julfou : Nan !
Squeezie : Euh Garfield ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Squeezie : Pfff... la vieille réf ! *Rire*
Squeezie : 'Tain on rame là hein !
Natoo : Est-ce que j'suis Black M ?
Squeezie : Bah déjà, déjà, tu vas attendre le sablier !
Natoo : Oui mais c'est parce que j'ai réfléchi !
Squeezie : Top !
Natoo : Est-ce que je suis Black M ?
Tous : Ouiiii !
Natoo : Je suis enfermée dans un lieu, je suis dans un pays ?
Cyprien : T'es dans un endroit !
Squeezie : T'es dans un endroit !
Natoo : Dans un endroit...
Natoo : À un repas de famille !?
Squeezie : Nooon
Cyprien : Pas loin !
Natoo : Euh... un anniversaire ?
Squeezie : Nan !
Squeezie : Top !
Julfou : Un acteur français ?
Squeezie : Ouais !
Julfou : Qu'a fait beaucoup de films ?
Cyprien & Squeezie : Ouais
Natoo : Beaucoup !
Julfou : Que vous aimez bien !?
Cyprien : Tout le monde l'aime !
Squeezie : On l'adore !
Julfou : Pas sportif du tout... Euh... Pas sportif du tout...
Julfou : Norman Thavaud ?
*Rire de Squeezie*
Natoo : Ooooooooohhhhhhh !
Natoo : Ça dénoonnce !
Squeezie : Ah le bâtard !
Julfou : Euh... qu'a joué dans beaucoup plus de films...
Cyprien : Terminé ! C'est parti !
Squeezie : Ok, donc dessin animé américain !
Cyprien : DESSIN ANIMÉ AMÉRICAIIIN !
Squeezie : American Dad !?
Natoo & Julfou : Nan !
Squeezie : Putain mais c'est pas possible !
Natoo : Mais t'en as cité qu'un !
Squeezie : Les Simpsons ? Les Simpsons ! Allez, c'est les Simpsons ! Les Simpsons alors...
Natoo : Aaaaah !
Cyprien : Je suis euh dans un groupe ?
Natoo : Ooooh...
Cyprien : Je suis vieux ?
Julfou : Tu l'as été, tu l'as été !
Natoo : Tu étais !
Cyprien : Et bah... j'suis un pote de Black M !?
Julfou : Oui !
Cyprien : Aaaah je suis Maître Gims !
Squeezie & Natoo : Ouiiiii !
Cyprien : Je suis dans un endroit ?
Squeezie : OSEF, nan, c'est pas important !
Natoo & Julfou : Nan !
Cyprien : Une activité ?
Squeezie & Natoo & Julfou : Ouais !
Cyprien : Je vais voir quelque chose ? Ah, je fais quelque chose !?
Julfou : Boire quelque chose il y a des chances, mais...
*Rires*
Squeezie & Julfou : Ça peut être quelque chose que tu portes !
Cyprien : Que je porte !?
Julfou : Ça peut mais...
Squeezie : Au choix, ça dépend !
Squeezie : Julfou ? Top !
Julfou : Euuuh...
Cyprien : Le plus connu de tous les acteurs français !
Julfou : J'ai fait un film cette année ?
Cyprien : Bah tout le temps ! Tous les 3 mois
Squeezie : Même si on a rien vu du film on sait qu'il y en a un qui sort !
Cyprien : Nan mais c'est ça, soit il tourne, soit il boit ! Donc euh...
Julfou : Gilles Lellouche !
*Rires*
Cyprien : Il boit !
Julfou : Ah, Depardieu !
Tous : Aaaaaah
Squeezie : Voilà putain !
Squeezie : Et il fait quoi ?
Julfou : Il picole !
*Rire de Cyprien*
Squeezie : Nan !
Julfou : Bah, Gérard Depardieu... ah il est dans un endroit ?
Squeezie : C'est fini ! C'est fini
Squeezie : C'est... c'est diffusé en France ?
Cyprien : Oui !
Julfou : Bien sûr
Squeezie : À la télé française ?
Cyprien : Oui !
Squeezie : Sur W9 ?
Julfou : J'en sais rien !
Cyprien : Je sais pas ! Franchement je sais pas !
Squeezie : Et bah voilà aussi !
Cyprien : Je fais une activité ?
Julfou : Tu fais une activité !
Natoo : Ouais
Cyprien : Une activité que j'ai déjà faite ?
Julfou : Oh oui !
Natoo : Oooooh !
*Rires*
Cyprien : Ah, que je fais souvent ?
squeezie : Ces derniers temps pas trop ! Ces derniers temps pas trop !
Natoo : Dans une crèche ? *Rire de Squeezie*
Cyprien : Nan !
Natoo : Avec mes parents ?
Cyprien : Pas loin, pas loin !
Natoo : C'est la fête des mères ?
Cyprien : Pas loin, nan !
Natoo : La fête des pères ?
Cyprien : Nan !
Natoo : Fête des grand-mères ! Dans une maison de retraite ?
Cyprien : La grand-mère, quand t'y vas...
Natoo : Bah chez Mamie !
Cyprien : Tu es donc...
Natoo : BLACK M CHEZ MAMIE !!
Cyprien : OUI !
*Applaudissements*
Squeezie : Par contre, les mecs, j'peux juste vous donner une petite info ?
Cyprien : Oui
Squeezie : J'ai toujours pas la moindre idée de que c'est ce PUTAIN de dessin animé !
Cyprien : Héhé, on va t'aider, on va t'aider !
Cyprien : C'est un dessin animé... américain, avec 4 garçons !
Squeezie : C'est un dessin animé américain avec 4 mecs...
Cyprien : Ils sont jeunes !
Squeezie : Nan mais mec...
Natoo : Mais NAAAN !
Squeezie : Ah si putain c'est South Park !?
Natoo : OUIIIIII !
Squeezie : Ah je suis un enculé !
Cyprien : Et tu es... ?
Squeezie : Alors, je suis South Park et alors...
Cyprien : Mais nan mais t'es pas South Park, tu peux pas être South Park
Squeezie : Ah merde c'est un mec ! Je suis Cartman ?
Cyprien & Natoo : MAIS OUIIII !
Squeezie : Je suis Kenny ? Cartman !
Squeezie (en imitant Cartman) : Ok
*Rire de Cyprien*
Squeezie (en imitant Cartman) : C'est un endroit ?
Squeezie : Je sais pas faire !
Natoo : Oui, c'est un endroit !
Squeezie : Oh oui ! Ok, c'est bon ! Ok alors je l'ai ! C'est parti Julfou !
Julfou : Gérard... Gégé...
Squeezie : Gégé !
Cyprien : Trouve l'endroit putain !
Julfou : Ah ! On est à la plage ?
Cyprien : Naan !
Squeezie : Nan !
Natoo : L'opposé !
Squeezie : L'opposé hein !
Julfou : L'opposé... dans un igloo ?
*Rires*
Squeezie : Un peu moins à l'opposé !
Natoo : Eh, tu vas à la...
Julfou : C'est dans la montagne !
Squeezie : Voilààà !
Squeezie (en imitant Cartman) : Ok les mecs !
Squeezie : C'est une zone géographique ?
Natoo & Julfou : Nan !
Squeezie : C'est un endroit... qu'il y a chez moi ?
Cyprien : Nope
Squeezie : C'est un endroit qu'il y a dans ma ville ?
Cyprien & Julfou : Oui !
Squeezie : C'est chiant ou c'est bien ?
Cyprien : Je déteste ça moi !
Squeezie : Tu détestes ça !?
Cyprien : T'as déjà été une fois ou 2 !
Squeezie : Moi !?
Cyprien : Ouais !
Squeezie (en riant) : Ok !
Cyprien : Je mets en ligne une vidéo ?
Squeezie & Julfou : Nan !
Cyprien : Je... tourne une vidéo ?
Cyprien : Je fais un placement de produit !?
Squeezie & Natoo & Julfou : Ouiiii !
Cyprien : Je suis Maître Gims qui fait un placement de produit !
Squeezie & Julfou : Oui !
Cyprien : YES !
Squeezie : Alors, qui va finir dernier une deuxième fois ?
*Rire de Cyprien*
Julfou : Olala...
Cyprien : Attention, ça se joue entre vous 2 !
Squeezie : Top !
Julfou : Euh... je suis... en après-ski ?
Natoo : Nan !
Julfou : Ah nan c'est pas... c'est un lieu !
Natoo : Un lieu !
Cyprien : Ça se passe que à la montagne !
Squeezie : Oh putain ! C'est ma seule chance de trouver frère ! C'est ma seule chance de trouver !
Squeezie : Donc, je suis allé 2 fois ! Est-ce qu'il faudrait que j'y aille, là, une nouvelle fois ?
Natoo : Franchement, nan, t'es bien !
Squeezie : J'suis bien !?
Squeezie : Est-ce que Cartman a raison d'y aller ?
Cyprien : Oui !
Squeezie : Est-ce que c'est parce qu'il est... gros ?
Squeezie : Cartman à la salle.
Cyprien : Ouiii !
Squeezie : Oooooooh !
Julfou : Aïe aïe aïe !
Julfou : Gérard Depardieu sur un télésiège ?
Cyprien & squeezie & Natoo : OUIIIII !
Squeezie : Les amis...
Cyprien : C'était fun hein !
Squeezie : C'était la fin de cette vidéo sur "Ta mère en slip" !
Cyprien (avec une voix de beauf) : Est-ce qu'on peut dire... que c'est le jeu de l'été clairement ?
Squeezie : C'est terminé, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne de Julfou, de Natoo, de Cyprien...
Squeezie : ...lui il débute en plus ! Il a grave besoin de soutien !
Cyprien : C'est vrai !
Squeezie : N'hésitez pas à faire beaucoup de placements de produit !
*Rire de Cyprien*
Squeezie : Ça rendra cette blague encore plus drôle et puis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo !
Squeezie : Merci d'être passés !
Natoo : Merciii !
Squeezie : Merci ! J'suis très tactile hein, je suis très très tactile !
Natoo : C'est très cool !
Squeezie : Merci à tous, merci à tous, merci à t... Ah ! T'as du sable ! Va-t-en, va-t-en !
Julfou : Mais arrêtez, mais arrêtez !
*Musique de fin*